turkey season but nothing is scary about
our next guest in fact I wish we got
more of what she has in those
trick-or-treat bags and here to give us
a little trick or cheese is the Wonder
Woman of cheese Diana
[Applause]
I'm so excited about this this is like
our one year anniversary of something
very exciting when you paired up this
magical pairing you take your kids candy
and you you pair it up with amazing
cheeses and this is the one year
anniversary of this one it was the
Reese's and what was the cheese the
cheese is called Adare Reserve it's a
mixed milk sheep and goat cheese from
The Basque region of France that is cave
aged and might ripened and has no
business being paired with peanut butter
cups but is the perfect Master pairing
that is one of the best things I have
ever tasted so I'm gonna save that for
last but you've got some other candy
pairings and let's start off with the
wine because this one I'm so excited
about telling I know about your
Hungarian Roots yeah and I always feel
like you know sometimes when you show up
to a party or a gathering of any kind
it's just nice to bring the host a
present but in spooky season we really
want to align with that so we actually
have a bottle in the shop called Bull's
blood and it's from igair in Northern
Hungary and it's like volcanic and
Limestone soil it's got like spicy red
fruits like green herbs on the nose and
on the palate it's just a beautiful wine
but I just love the name Bull's blood
for like a Halloween Gathering like host
gift so really really a special bottle
retails like under 25. are you kidding
that is delicious
I love this this is starting off the
party right this season for sure okay
let's do some candy pairings okay what
do you have so this over here is a um a
mini chewy Sweet Tart so put pop one in
first okay then you're going to want to
chew it a couple of times the weird
thing here with cheese and Halloween
candy pairings is that sometimes
texturally they're just a little bit
different on the palette until they
combine go ahead and add this cheese
this is actually Aries from shooting
star Creamery domestically produced out
of Paso Robles this is a sheep's milk
Alpine style it's going to take a minute
on the palette it but then what happens
is they actually integrate beautifully
it's the sower of the candy interacting
with the high butter fat of the sheep
milk and the acidity of it being an
Alpine style why do we why don't we
combine all our candies with cheese
that's delicious oh my God we need to
play more as adults and if that means
stealing our kids candy I'm here for it
okay I'm worried about this this is this
candy corn and we only have a couple
seconds left so I can record and truffle
two of the most polarizing things that
you can put on your palate so put them
together because sheet milk cheese and
truffle are both natural pairings with
honey so because candy corn has a lot of
that honey characteristic to it when
they combine on the palette you are
getting an experience unlike anything do
I eat them together eat those together
oh my gosh candy I don't like it no she
needs candy corn so I did it again this
year okay we did it differently
it's gonna be perfect because all of a
sudden that honey is going to integrate
onto that palette right alongside the
Truffle it's going to combine
beautifully and you won't even know that
there's candy corn I don't hate candy
corn anymore what just happened because
truffle cheese is it's crazy where can
people find you Diana I'm the belly
cheese and wine I'm in Henderson on
Horizon Ridge
um we are in just this cute little
McDonald Ranch area we do happy hours we
do pop-up events we are having Halloween
parties website